mes chers amis
2022 est une année déterminante pour
nous vous le savez tout d'abord je
voudrais à tous et à toutes vous
souhaitez tous mes voeux de bonheur de
santé de réussite pour vous pour vos
proches pour vos familles et maintenant
sur le sur le plan politique vous savez
le chemin que nous avons parcouru depuis
maintenant deux ans nous avons d'abord
remporté toutes les victoires
électorales sur le terrain les
municipales les sénatoriales les
départementales les régionales et
maintenant nous sommes axés sur la
présidentielle nous avons réussi notre
congrès avec la désignation notre
candidate et et autour d'elle s'est
constitué une véritable équipe de france
d'abord avec les autres candidats mais
ensuite avec notre famille politique
rassemblée avec un mouvement de jeunesse
qui a repris naissance les jeunes
républicains ça existe nous sommes très
présents sur le terrain 150 mille
militants aujourd'hui répartis dans
toute la métropole et l'outre-mer et
donc il nous faut maintenant transformer
cet essai et vous savez que un cinquième
république
l'élection présidentielle c'est la clé
de voûte donc il faut à tout prix gagner
7 cette présidentielle pour cela une
seule chose être mobilisés rassemblés
autour de valérie pécresse elle a su
nous démontrer ses qualités d'abord
dirigé la plus grande collectivité
territoriale de france celle d'île de
france mais au-delà de ça vous l'avez vu
et vous avez vu son attachement au
régaliens aux mesures fortes sur la
sécurité sur l'autorité de l'état mais
aussi sur les sujets du pouvoir d'achat
sur les retraités sur la jeunesse à qui
il faut redonner un espoir il faut pas
regarder l'avenir dans un rétroviseur il
faut être tournés vers vers l'avenir
c'est ce qu'elle sait ce qu'elle fait en
permanence avec un vrai projet porteur
d'espoir nous avons besoin d'elle et
nous avons besoin de vous c'est ensemble
que nous gagnerons nous avons avec
valérie pécresse chef de file une
candidate remarquable pour gagner ces
élections présidentielles mais il faut
maintenant se mobilisent et non pas à
100 ou à 200 % mais à 2000% donne tout
ce que l'on peut donner sur les quatre
mois qui viennent je vous fais confiance
et je suis sûr qu'ensemble nous
gagnerons cette élection présidentielle
et dans la foulée les élections
législatives bonne année à tous
[Musique]